oh go and rest my name is Reba and
welcome to uh why don't you this if I
can kill me right here
cozy I don't know what we're gonna play
but I got I got comment saying I don't
play scary games enough and what the
[ __ ] is that little thing doing
son of a [ __ ] shaped my phone alright
let's see what we got here sounds spooky
bar being the great scooby-doo surged
okay that sounds it's hard enough yes
let's do this alright Barbie
skipper there is missing what could it
be I mean this was pretty [ __ ] scary
if you ask me I have to find them yes
click he was fearless
Scooby though
no no I don't want to click things why
all of that behind the shelf
[ __ ] click all that [ __ ] click on
scrub is go away
congratulations what is your first name
oops what's wrong with my name but son
of a [ __ ] what is wrong with my name
but game Joe but Jay Jay alright thanks
for fighting scooby-doo you're amazing
I bet apprentice alright
that's not ever play that again shot ah
how the [ __ ] I want to kill you alright
bike by styling stuff alright here we go
bike styling right take a back with
Barbie they're all locked change clothes
let's do that they gotta wear a helmet
Barbie nothing is changing about these
outfits first track all right [ __ ] yeah
get all the diamonds
pimping Bobby get your back Marty calm
down
there we go baby crazy son of a [ __ ]
bar one bar b bar y oh yes I got a new
top yes
lap dance what all right here we go baby
Barbie you crazy Oh Bobby calm your tits
what's your hair going on what are you
doing Bobby yeah [ __ ] yeah
last lap [ __ ] alright here we go
front left
now you can't front flip
can you front-flip i wanna strike italy
ah that guy finish it I wonder if
there's a way to not actually finish I'm
good let's check our outfit oh holy [ __ ]
this is amazing
I am loving this can I print my diploma
alright and see where that shot ah party
race Craig we have this little said get
to
all right let's try that what the hell
am I doing with my life
all right here we go - look at that
little [ __ ] I'll let you just flush her
down all right I'm a babysitter
first floor purrfect potty come on click
on the open atom eating distractions
I guess I have to take a [ __ ] now I get
destruction good why am I sick Barney
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh like you're not controlling it I got
a bar a bar at your [ __ ] honor that
and take a [ __ ] no get a stripe in mud
stop vomit get out yeah son of a [ __ ]
oh wait all right then you go in here
excellent
don't get distracted you have to take a
[ __ ] [ __ ] off aah Barbie why are you
doing this to me
[Music]
don't look at the mirror where's she
going now
that's stupid [ __ ] don't that's right
[ __ ] teleporting yes Garnett and tag
that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh we gotta do that again we got a spin
C and B on C alright alright let's make
your [ __ ] ourselves that is this
fantastic oh oh my god you gotta [ __ ]
yourself girl
I [ __ ] love the music - this is
everything about this gameis is -
amazing
alright get affected you have to take a
[ __ ] but the thing is - shut up toilet
paper
[ __ ] no no no you're not getting got it
ah she got toilet paper now that son of
a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] alright go to the good
time guys I think I got hit gonna do
come on fine going here you guys can't
happen no no no no no no no no no no no
no stupid I know I know I just say that
No all right let's do math number three
and now [ __ ] I got a diploma and [ __ ]
purrfect potty sticker that's what I got
I'm ready
all right she's gonna [ __ ] herself sit
the son of a [ __ ] not doing anything
for you putting this ha ha ha duck go
closer teleport down to a duck
you're in my sight here's something
dougie kill hi redhead do something
debate the Taliban choice
yes it's never gonna finish this game
stupid [ __ ] you're not even gonna get
perfect party girl oh I block your shot
looks like it long [ __ ] [ __ ] or some
[ __ ] I don't know
why am i dirty it's fast we're checking
fast-forward some [ __ ] Barbie why are
you doing this
all right time's running up the action
let's make it a challenge no I don't
want a challenge
she's so [ __ ] go over there what is
this house anyway bye ohoo dick grades
like this well that's a [ __ ] dog that
looks like that sit down by ah ah you're
gonna [ __ ] yourself girl ya gotta shut
it that it's gonna be beautiful today's
show me a movie come on I know you [ __ ]
down the carpet buddy I was that's fun
let's never do that again
so yeah if you have any more scary games
please suggest them in the comments and
I'll be sure to play them like babies
you know I just got home rigid and I'll
see you next episode on me Sammy oh and
this was a joke in case you didn't get
that first Barbie video I made people
didn't get the [ __ ] joke alright
that's us
[Music]
everyone come down all right wake up
hey guys that I've got Hosanna bin
highlight grass on Facebook I do